las mujeres monopolizaron la mirada del
jurado del festival de cannes con dos
cintas una africana y una europea
[Música]
el director chadiano radicado en
francia- mahamat saleh harún regresó al
festival de cannes con lynn y los
vínculos sagrados un drama que evoca el
tema tabú del aborto y de la escisión de
las niñas en chad
no
es una mujer relegada por su comunidad y
por su propia familia por haber tenido
una hija fuera del matrimonio en un país
regido por la religión la situación se
vuelve aún más difícil cuando su hija
maría sale embarazada a los 15 años y le
anuncia que desea abortar amina se lanza
entonces en una carrera llena de
obstáculos para ayudar a su hija a poner
fin a su embarazo no va a terminar la
rompen acaban ahí ocurre pena con esta
imagen ha hecho con este otros vocales
la quinto jurada y sheila como galicia
si link y los vínculos sagrados muestra
también la condición de las niñas
asfixiadas por una sociedad
ultraconservadora y es uno de los seis
largometrajes africanos que aspiran a la
palma de oro
de noruega nos llega una heroína
melancólica y entrañable del prodigioso
joachim trier
cómo
y diez años después de haber
impresionado en cannes con oslo 31 de
agosto y ahora sin traer regresa con
julia en 12 capítulos el retrato
delicado de una joven mujer de hoy a
través de sus dudas existenciales y sus
historias de amor
yo sintiera sed de julia un símbolo de
la juventud contemporánea al tiempo que
evoca temáticas sociales como el
movimiento mitú o la preocupación
medioambiental